so you're an idealist that wants to
change the world you view the world as
corrupt and oppressive it has nothing to
do with you drinking smoking partying
all the time willingly taking on massive
amounts of debt refusing to pick up a
book no that has nothing to do with it
it's the system's fault
your first instinct is to exclaim if we
don't get what we want we're gonna burn
the system down and make a new one while
also screaming stereotypical rhetoric
like calling people pigs or white
fascist racist with a healthy amount of
profanity sprinkled in between of course
if you're on the other side maybe you
want to scream from the rooftops you
dirty no-good commies but before you do
that ask yourself who is that gonna
change is it gonna change the
middle-class mom that's just trying to
provide for her kids how about the
husband that may not have that much but
is working towards a promotion and has
his eyes on a new car are you gonna
change their minds by wanting to burn
down everything they've worked for no
you're really gonna make a fool of
yourself we have to be sneakier more
subtle in our methods of insurrection so
whether you're an idealist or maybe
you're in or want to be in the 1% and
you want to prevent the plebeian masses
from stripping you down we have to learn
how to communicate the changes we want
in a way that actually gets through
people's thick heads sure you can call
people racist or economy's all day well
you're never gonna get them on your side
and that is where the real power is or
in other words we have to learn the arts
of the revolution revolutions are not
human society revolutions don't have to
be communist revolutions either as its
associated with today all a revolution
really is is a change from whatever the
status quo was at a time that means if
the current system is communist in the
revolution can be a capitalist one if
the current system is a crony capitalist
one the revolution could be a communist
socialist or even a more capitalistic
one revolutions don't have to be violent
either it can happen right underneath
our fingertips
for example Elon Musk is the main
revolutionary of the ideology more on
that later
the humans should be an interplanetary
species no bullets will be fired in this
interplanetary revolution but a
revolution is still is revolutions come
about because humans are always pursuing
their own self-interest nothing around
with that some of those self-interested
humans finds a
and gain power that power breeds more
power and oftentimes leads to corruption
which lays subsequent humans to become
resentful of said humans and power and
boom revolution and at the core of it
all is the neverending power struggle
between the haves the have-nots and the
have a little want mores the haves are
pretty simple they say at the top of the
hierarchy have the most resources and
are the smallest number because they're
so well-off at the top why on earth what
they want things to change change
threatens their power so there's no hope
in trying to convert them they're set in
their establishment ways they profit off
in the status quo because they're at the
top everyone is trying to tear them down
and get a piece on their very big pie so
one of their biggest worries is losing
everything that they have that have-nots
are also pretty simple they're by far
the largest and number at the very
bottom of the hierarchy from the most
part they resent the haves the upper
class and view them as simply getting
rich off of their aching tired backs
whether that's true or not they also
hate the upper classes legal system
their police their opulence they're
trapped together by poverty disease low
skills ignorant and despair what the
upper class has the power of resources
the only power the lower class has is
the power of their sheer numbers they
feel pretty hopeless and because they
have such huge pain points it's very
easy to sway them with the right leader
in place you can very easily fan the
flames of their suffering for your
revolution and because they're already
at the lowest of the low
once that flame starts the only
direction they can go is up
and then there's the half a little want
some more crowd also known as the middle
class stuck right in the middle of the
middle class are torn between two paths
on one hand they want to uphold the
current system to protect the little
wealth that they have and to hopefully
move into the upper class by playing by
the rules on the other hand they also
see the temptation to overthrow the
status quo so they can join in on
pillaging the rich for some instant
gratification this makes the middle
class have sort of a split personality
to revolution or to not revolution an
example of this was perfectly
illustrated with the rhesus stimulus
checks
because they're in a complacent spot
things are going okay I guess most of
the middle class or do-nothings
on one hand though preach for social
justice change equality they'll take
part in the latest social media trends
show support and make them feel like
such a good noble person but in reality
they're not gonna do much and will
typically choose the safe route to make
sure they come out on top and every
single revolution can be traced back to
these three classes the house have the
power the have-nots become resentful of
their power that resentment simmers over
time until boom revolutionaries
overthrow the haves then there's a
period of that necessarily piece but
calmness until the revolutionaries
slowly or quickly in some cases morph
into the same system they once condemned
and the revolutionary clock is set right
back to where it first started so is the
tragedy of human civilization but before
you get violent and burn the system down
I urge you not to let's say you start a
revolution a coup right now and you take
control of the government if the middle
class is still feeling complacent with
the current system if all the have-nots
aren't fired up behind you that people
in power you're trying to overthrow will
swiftly crush you why because you didn't
have the massive support you didn't lay
the groundwork for revolution kind of
like what happened in Seattle's
autonomous zone or the recently
attempted coup in Venezuela revolutions
happen before a single shot is ever
fired it happens when all the have-nots
agree that yes we finally had enough it
happens when the majority of the middle
class say I'm not sure how I feel about
revolution but as long as they leave me
alone I'm not gonna fight against it or
in other words it happens when your
populace is right for revolution much
like how bananas get right for eating as
we mentioned before in our video on mass
psychology the memorable events of
history are the visible effects of the
invisible changes of human thought treat
your revolution like a movie there's an
act one where the stage is set the
problem is presented the good and bad
guys were distinguished then comes Act
two what the tension bills the pressure
turns up and things slowly crescendo
into act three the climax of your
revolution along with the aftermath a
lot of these idealist want to jump
straight into the climax but without the
foreplay your revolution will fall flat
on its knees
as John Adams wrote the Revolution was
affected before the war commenced the
revolution was in the hearts and minds
of the people this radical change in the
principles opinions sentiments and
affections of the people was the real
American Revolution so that's your real
job changed the public's mind first make
them feel disgusted and enslaved by the
system but not to enslaved to where they
feel they can't do anything about it and
your revolution will take care of itself
if you're a part of the house and power
to prevent revolution your job is to
keep your place feeling complacent and
submissive it's as simple as that
now that our foreplay is done let's get
into the nitty-gritty details of your
revolution all revolutions start with an
ideology an idea that the masses can
rally behind against those evil men in
charge something that can get people to
move past their primitive instincts of
putting their own well-being before
others something that ordinary lower in
middle class people who are just trying
to get by are willing to die for that's
a big ask that's why all ideologies that
have led the revolutions of the past
have always been around grand ideas like
justice equality and freedom whether or
not those revolutionary leaders actually
believe in those things is a different
story
the point is ideologies are
wedding-night revolutions and your job
is to nurture and infect the ideology of
your choosing into as many people as
possible every ideology has one central
idea where everything stems from the
Marxist central idea is that evil lies
in the greedy capitalist exploiting the
poor old proletariat's
the libertarian central ideas that evil
eyes and big government's suffocating
poor old individuals so pick your
ideology and spread your gospel you do
this by working in the very system that
you despise this can be done via
spreading propaganda I mean educating
the public and schools on the internet
etc this also means getting into
politics passing bills starting
nonprofits protesting or maybe even
donating money to people that can do it
for you all with the goal of slowly
getting that drumbeat of revolution
rising one insanely effective tactic you
can use is the angry mob use some kind
of emotional tragic event to rally up an
angry mob that demands change with that
angry mob behind you you can use them to
publicly shame people that disagree with
you and to make demands since the middle
class usually looks for the safe way out
and the half
are worried about losing what they have
at the hands of an angry mob no easily
submit to your demands without putting
up a fight but be wary go too far and
you'll rest building resentment against
the crowd which will eventually backfire
now you may be saying to yourself but
Jake this sounds like a lot of work I
want change now and you're right it does
take a lot of work changing the culture
of millions of people takes time but
what's the alternative we already
covered how calling people racist or
commies doesn't help except in the
context of an angry mob and overthrowing
the system without laying down the
groundwork doesn't help either on top of
that the battle over the minds of the
public may not even be won in your
lifetime depending on where you are in
the revolutionary clock you may not even
live to see the day where revolution
happens so you may be wondering what the
purpose of all this is which is a fair
points but what is life without a
greater purpose without something bigger
to fight for in my opinion that's not a
life worth living now you may be
wondering but Jake aren't you trying to
change culture with these videos and to
that our reply absolutely I am here as a
revolutionary to propagate the ideology
of self-reliance of curiosity of being a
dangerous individual and if you can't
get behind that ideology and I don't
know what to tell you but if you can get
behind those ideas well then there's a
subscribe button and a notification bell
below and all of us have an agenda don't
let anyone tell you otherwise but at
least I am it mine if you want to
support the channel financially consider
checking out the course I made on how to
land a remote job with the link below
that's how I got my start in this hole
make money online world and that is what
I recommend for others as well if you
want more day in the life kind of stuff
behind the scenes kind of stuff memes
you can follow me on instagram at j
trend io that is gonna wrap it up for
this video this is like the third time
I'm recording this because I messed up
like twice so yeah thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome I've been
Jake I'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]